土曜日で8時
今日は空いてる
今日は
今日は大丈夫だと
一番危ないのは
受体じゃない
受体で
高速で止まってる
夜は見えないから
2時間目
3時間目
2時間半から3時間
早くて2時間
早くて2時間半
普通に行くと3時間ぐらい
休憩しないで2時間半
休憩しないで渋滞全然なくて
うちまでだとちょうど2時間半くらい
まあだいたいちょっと休んだりして
3時間以上
違って
夏の最後のコースが コロナになってからいろいろオンラインになって意外とこうやって
なんか日本に行ったりとか コロナになってからいろいろオンラインになって
それっきりいろいろ便利になったから
オンラインの方が楽でしょ?
日本に行かなくてもいいし 日本に行っても授業が受けられる
日本で授業を受けられない
あと夜の間だから
2歳があるから
そうから夜って
夜の勉強しながら
朝の1時から
1時?
3時かな
1時から
今日も
13時間
こっち13時間
違いで
これもまだちょっと大変だね
夜中に便利しなきゃいけない
ちょっとくらいね
9時くらいからさ
1時から勉強
頭が
でも逆になっちゃうね
暮らしがもう
夜は逆転しちゃうね
昼夜が
でも毎日じゃないの?
うんうん
いや毎日じゃない
でしょ
録画とかで決める?
そういうわけですか?
いやできる
なんか他の生徒ズルしてる子がいて
なんか
問題になったよね大学で
うちの大学で
単位を早く欲しいから